liberal leaders patting themselves on
the back because the murder was targeted
and not random unfortunately that's the
sad state of San Francisco the man
suspected of stabbing to death Tech
Mogul bubbly charged with murder today
and police say Lee knew his killer San
Francisco's Democrat mayor London breed
practically gloating over that she's
trying to score some political points
and hit back at critics who've been
blasting her cities unsafe
I think that oftentimes because of
social media because of cameras and how
people are able to publicize things that
are happening in a moment it is taken
completely out of context in terms of
highlighting the entire city as being
unsafe that's not entirely true it's sad
because I think it's just San Francisco
has been a target for so long and used
as an example because we're Innovative
we're creative we come up with out of
the box ideas and a number of other
things to push forward change in our
communities and I think that sadly you
know with the previous president it was
a Target
people are getting fed up with the
nonsense too Lawrence Jones actually
went to San Francisco to talk to
Democrats about far-left measures that
put criminals back on the streets and
the voters there say they got tricked
listen
who thought it was a good idea does
anybody is anybody in support of it
apparently the voters did yeah yeah I
mean I don't well because it was sold as
the safe schools act come on who doesn't
want to vote for myself if you've never
voted in the state of California yeah
you have to understand that we get these
books that are this thick we all thought
it was a certain thing but it was sold
as the safe schools initiative so we're
like who doesn't want safe schools
and even Al Sharpton's warning Democrats
that crime could be the party's downfall
anybody
that tells you they Progressive but
don't care about dealing with violent
crime are not Progressive for who
we got to stop using Progressive as a
noun and use it as an adjective
your labor is Progressive but your
action is regressing I'm woke
you must think I'm asleep
it's gotten so bad even Puro and
Sharpton agree on something yeah
right but think about
Cisco which is I mean we've been talking
about it for months here it's it's about
the social media and it's about
um um the the cameras and it's about uh
the perception of crime it's not really
about crime because if you take the
murder of Bobby Lee it's really not
about San Francisco because he was
targeted by somebody and therefore it's
not like Street crime so I guess a
Pelosi case shouldn't be counted as a
crime in San Francisco because it was
targeted against Nancy and her husband
in their house so I mean how'd they get
to these mental gymnastics is is more
than I can understand but if they're
saying that only Street crime is the
kind of crime that can be linked to
their City she has more than enough of
it and the reason she has more than
enough of it is because she cut the PD
120 million dollars when she was in
favor of defund the police now I'm
starting to think it's not about
um you know a war of policies it's
really about a war of words and that was
the last thing that was going on uh with
Lawrence Jones you know how could you be
against something that is for safe
schools or safe this or that they pretty
much sabotage they take the language it
becomes a war of words who controls the
words who controls the narrative and so
they say you know that that they're
winning and and the rest of us are are
fools and we don't really understand
what's going on because they're for safe
cities even though they're cities and
their policies are criminal Martha do
you buy the excuse that we were tricked
we didn't know what we were voting for
well I think that there's a long history
of creative naming of of bills and
referendums uh that make people feel bad
if they don't vote for them and I think
he's right A lot of people don't read
some of the five fine print that goes
along with a lot of these bills but I'm
struck by the fact that Marilyn and
breed says that they think outside the
box and that they're creative I mean
tell that to these businesses that have
needles outside their their businesses
people sleeping in their doorways you
know I have you know people try talk to
people in San Francisco who always vote
liberal and they are up to here they've
had it so you can have a war of words
which I think is a very uh sort of
skillful attempt but eventually it
doesn't work anymore because people get
it they know their life experience they
see what's happening in front of them
and even this situation with Bob Lee he
was stabbed you know there's all kinds
of new details coming out in the in the
documents around this that it was
something about his sister and that uh
he wanted to know if anything
inappropriate had happened with his
sister and the text messages back and
forth he was stabbed he went from car to
car trying to get someone to help him
what is that reflective of it's
reflective of a city where everybody's
scared right they don't want to help oh
my God there's somebody bleeding next
thing I know there's going to be a gun
coming out and someone's going to get
shot if I stop to help what's going to
happen to me that's a mentality that is
existing in the city so it is not
separate from what plagues the
population in San Francisco about
knowing that they're not safe ask Paul
Pelosi it's true Greg gutfield what'd
you think of London breed's comments
well you know it's it's I it's kind of
weird when like one person's last
moments are now a political boast uh you
know it's like it's like
this is this probably the worst Victory
lap I've ever seen I mean the city that
the the ACT is so this somehow restores
sf's golden reputation because it wasn't
a random murder how pathetic is that and
that somehow Bob Lee's death disproves
all other deaths you know and so this is
a murder that they're okay with never
mind it it didn't
his murder didn't stand out because
there was so much crime going on in the
fabric of the city that when it happened
it happened after other murders and
happened before murders so that just so
happens that this was done by somebody
he knows that doesn't disprove anything
else how bad is it how bad is it for a
city when this is your relief I mean and
it is disgusting and you know you've
reached Peak absurdity when Al Sharpton
says we got to get tough on crime
anybody close to my age or older knows
Al Sharpton wasn't wasn't Pro crime for
half his life but it's a sign that
leftism has moved so far to the left
that it's left Al Sharpton in a new
middle like if Charles Manson was alive
he'd be saying I'm moving he'd be
calling U-Haul to move out of California
but he reveals I think Sharpton reveals
an un uh an unspeakable truth that we've
been saying here nothing hurts blacks
more than white liberals right I mean
white Libs unlike black constituents
excuse criminal Behavior they condemn
police presence they're usually the
Jokers who are behind that absurd
reparations uh a number that the funding
and the clearing of Prisons uh bind all
those things you'll always find a pasty
white leftist and usually it's the black
constituents that are going like get
this person out of our Lives we want
Cops in our neighborhoods we just don't
want bad cops left it white leftists
never say that they say no cops blacks
say good cops that it's a difference I'm
sure I'm sure you would agree with me
yeah it's important to see you by the
way these whites are a huge problem
aren't they I dare you say it here
whites are terrible my wife is watching
and so are my children
yeah
um it's good to be back too I agree with
you that people I know blacks whites
people who want Public Safety who Dean
Public Safety judges a big part of why
they vote for certain politicians want
good police officers we want more of
them I've said on this show more cops
ending Cassius Bell attacking ghost guns
perhaps building more prisons if that's
what we need to ensure we have Public
Safety particularly neighborhoods that
oftentimes are hit the hardest by this
Jesse that's what we need I watch Kevin
O'Leary Earl he might was he on your
shoes on he was on one of the shows
earlier
um talking about talking about
how bad policies of forcing uh
disinvestment in businesses to lead
communities which is another form of
this investment he said it's not
politics it's policy and I think
Democrat Republican alike and we should
we should you know the mayor all Mayors
want to try to make their cities sound
better I do agree with you this is a
strange Victory lap but at the same time
I I understand what she's saying but
she'd spend a lot it'd be a lot better
expenditure of time if you've got the
council together and tried to figure out
how do we prevent these things from
happening going forward that's what she
should have said during that interview
oh she could have could have said look
people think so poorly the city we are
not the city you think but we need to do
better and here's what I'm announcing
and I I think I think unfortunately
politicians today get get so
thin-skinned with remember this is a
national problem eight out of ten States
but the highest murder rates happen to
be governed by Republicans I don't stop
it
now it's not good this year isn't in
charge of law enforcement but the Mayors
are the most important person the most
important voice I saw a minute ago was
something you said about Reverend
Sharpton I don't think he's been 40
years like for Crime but for him to
stand up and before progressives and say
progressive for who yeah if you're
really serious about bringing about
investment making schools better
creating better Public Safety in
communities that progressives purport to
want to to try to try to achieve listen
to him him and listen to those of us
around a table who are not talking about
this politically or racially we're
talking about it from the standpoint of
Public Safety if we don't do that the
policies get worse and that means
business and money and opportunity and
education opportunity in particular
leave the communities we need them in
most black kids killed at a rate five
times the rate of white children in
cities in America and that's what she
should be focused but I'll tell you this
even if we're white if it were white
kids being killed five times I still
want public safeties I think that that's
the issue here
right no no I know we all want safety
but the fact is that we get so much
attention sometimes on the school
shootings which obviously are important
stories but but what we miss is all of
the everyday violence
shows the pictures of these children I
agree 100 because I think we all agree
that white Liberals are the problem yes
yes hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else